thank you
[Music]
all right this is something that
happened in 2017. it's it's a while back
but the reason I'm bringing up today is
because the results are
in
what happened so this happened in
Nashville there's this uh she's a
relatively successful singer her name is
Katie Lane uh originally from Texas she
gets into her Porsche that's parked on
the street
the engine noise and the fumes Disturbed
like a nearby homeless guy who's
chilling there and he asks her like hey
can you move
and then uh she gets out and as he's
walking away she shoots him twice
she just called Cole kills a homeless
man for asking her he didn't die he
didn't die so she shoots him twice and
then proceeds to like most people go to
Taco Bell and then
um the guy ends up you know uh he ends
up Surviving after like extensive
surgeries back then 2017 she was
originally charged with attempted first
degree murder aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon as you do
um and today she is found guilty of
nothing more than reckless endangerment
what in the [__] wow because Texas I
don't know it's some backward [__] right
well at least she has bad I thought that
was Cali but then in Cali you would
probably get the death penalty for
shooting almost person but here I was
like how the [__] did this happen
because it's the opposite I think in
California if you get assaulted then you
go to jail but in Texas yeah you call
you you murder somebody in Cold Blood
and then the whole family goes to jail
and then you become celebrated yeah
right what does she look like I gotta
see a picture oh great these are never
gonna go well when you here you go I
gotta see what she looks like
she looks like a Kardashian cute
100 I wouldn't expect her to shoot a
homeless guy no definitely not but I do
expect her to eat afterwards no dude she
doesn't look crazy yeah Taco Bell
definitely makes sense to that she looks
like she loves the number three at Taco
Bell which one's the number three
I think it's the chalupas
chalupas dude
that just came back
the bumped it down a little here's a
sentence that she actually gets 11
months and 21 29 days of probation
what that's it holy [__]
was there something here like the story
was different from what we're told like
let's say like the first story is oh the
Holmes man just said move and then the
second story was oh no he actually was
like assaulting her so she had to shoot
him no so it just gets all mixed up and
[__] she had um there was a witness in
her she had another person in her car so
that's the person that was able to
corroborate not told on her but like
but like she claims that she was just
trying to scare him away because she
felt threatened even though he was
unarmed and you know
um I just think it's pretty [__]
remarkable that she actually did hit him
she shot him twice yeah and showed no
remorse getting a [__] chalupa
afterwards maybe it's because he's
homeless though
it's like oh he's just a homeless guy so
then that could be different like he's
gonna recover well no our society
doesn't really care about homeless
people
[Laughter]
and then we drive around them like maybe
it's just some some just the general
[__] that we do already
yeah the judge is like oh I mean we
could have gotten rid of one more but
that would have been easy but you know
right I'm sure pigeons better than they
treat homeless people is that true
because people think about grabbing
bread so they can give to pigeons later
and like oh don't feed the Homeless no
no no no it just makes them angry yeah
yeah
all right so the crazy thing to me is
like I in my head I don't know if this
is just my wrong impression
here in Cali it's pretty [__] severe
to [__] with homeless people like law
wise I think you get kind of you're
screwing yourself over a little bit
because it's a punch down yeah I thought
remember when they they gave homeless
people like tiny homes and then the city
ended up taking them away because
they're like these are probably like a
fire hazard or some [__] it seems like
the city like pretends like they love
homeless people but then they don't yeah
well because they had to do work right
so oh we already built it are we gonna
disband this uh sector no wait let's
make more work yeah take them apart put
them back together take it apart yeah
it's perpetual but I I really was
genuinely surprised that this happened
so that's a loophole if you ever shoot
anybody just be like whoa I was feeling
threatened by a homeless man I was just
trying to scare them off homeless or not
because it sounds like you could just
shoot I think maybe she just got a
really good jury yeah yeah
I think she had a really good sob story
or something what do you think she looks
like she cries in court she looked like
she just finished crying the main things
that she does say that they're not that
sobby is that like so she was she's been
wrapped in this case for like five years
you said she's a musician right yeah
she's a singer it's probably her music
is just it's probably really they're all
fat it's really good because music can
make you overlook anybody really yep
everyone's like they probably use the R
Kelly [__] music debate versus the
stuff that he did in real life killing
her R Kelly would have got away with it
if he didn't do all his new albums yeah
ruin his legacy yeah yeah the trapped in
a closet Saga just really did it for me
yeah MJ got away with it all all Michael
did he just did a remasters he didn't do
some [__] he just was like all right
I'll just make this a little bit better
you don't want Sully you don't want to
sell your brand image yeah right I
didn't think of it that way that's bad
music business he did so this is it shut
up dude she did say that um that's why
she did say that she feels like socially
she's been convicted because like she
kind of can't really you know so many
people hate her really yeah
why and they kind of also hate that
she's getting away with it so it's like
she's like hey like I'm [__]
career-wise anyway so maybe pick a move
she can move she can move there's Taco
Bells everywhere you're in Nashville and
you're a singer
you're probably a specific type of
singer where you shouldn't probably be
in Nashville yeah that's a demographic
yeah um she could change her genre I
want to hear her music now she does
country
I'm guessing she does something that
would thrive in Nashville so it's
probably not drum and bass wow
she can do more like that [__] what's
his name the gangster ass country guy
not James Dean little Nas x no the
[__]
the the guy that they did a movie about
him and he's talking about the [__]
Folsom Prison Blues oh Johnny Johnny
Cash Mr Cash she could do the Mrs cash
[__] I shot a homeless man [__]
here for a second because he killed a
man in [__] Reno just to watch him
die right so like now she I [__] shot
a homeless man at Taco Bell just to see
him kind of run away
[Laughter]
it's not lyrically strong but it's true
it's in the works yeah she um the funny
thing is you know when someone's up for
uh for trial they start bringing up
other [__] they've done to like kind of
slay the opinion some of these things
sound really funny it's like during the
trial the jury heard that once she had
threatened to harm a child with a brick
and made threats against people
including her mother and poured water on
a woman in a restaurant like these
little side things are hilarious
diminish her character character yeah
yeah it can be lady cash
it's like Snoop Dogg after he had that
murder case he had the [__] song and
he came out with that album but it was
the case that they gave me and then so
she could do that [__] too and it might
be saving her career yeah yeah hey if
you're watching this you should be her
lawyer I will manage her name's Katie
Quackenbush go ahead and talk Katie
quacking Bush she used to be a rapper
now that's her real name that's her real
name
we're gonna Rebrand it yeah we need to
get a stage name quack attack we're
gonna call it the quack attack all right
yeah and then pat pat quack attack okay
and you your your whole genre now is
like well country is almost like Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop it's just white people talking
about like ghetto white people and mud
white people and driving they even have
rapping sometimes in country music yep I
mean and then all she's got to do now is
just
be the lady Johnny Cash
as I have been saying there you go Katie
that's your answer yeah that's how you
figure it out we'll just talk about
gangster [__] you're welcome I honestly
think anybody in the world can write a
country music song it's like it's the
easiest [__] ever to write a lot of
stuff about trucks t-shirt yeah it's fun
though do you like country she's only
32. no I hate country it's awful I'm a
Bluegrass kind of guy and I don't think
it's the same you like that plane gas is
great yup I love it if she's complaining
about the social part of that she could
just like chill in jail
that's true she's out she's free chill
in jail you know what I mean it's like
she's off the hook like that's crazy
great alternative 11 and a half months
of just probation yeah I want to know
more about the story about her
threatening a kid with a brick that's
what was more interesting I don't want
to know what she ordered to talk about
after that incident the number three the
chalupa she always goes I I don't know
I'm sure that's what people were
discussing in jury deliberation what did
you order I'm gonna look up if Taco
Bell's number three is really true
it's a rebranding one of her songs
should be called chalupa bullets
chalupa bullets and how she got a street
cred from shooting somebody some guy
outside of Taco Bell street cred that's
album Number Two that's pretty I'm still
really I'm duck hunting at Taco Bell can
we hear one of our tracks like a snake
reckless endangerment